good morning John it is Wednesday
November 3rd song Wednesday and this is
a song that I wrote
it's about Phineas Gage Phinney's dave
was 25 years old
15:48 and he liked his job looking at
the railroad but he had another face
[Music]
something distracted
with the damping
capiche from attending rod into that
little
along to the blasting powder and
suddenly is the entire left funnel over
been turned into clam chowder
the story of being the estate she was
stabbed in the brain and what a frontal
lobe has been destroyed you could never
go home again
[Music]
Phineas Gage was sitting on his bed
until the dock of the dampening ride
shat straight through his head
for that
Casey surely won't be
but then Phineas had a coughing fit and
a teacup full of brains fell out of his
head and that was
than the doctor could explain
the story of Phineas Gage she was happy
and what the frontal lobe has been
destroyed you can never go home again
well the doctor told the family to
prepare for gages death cuz the one you
take before your head gets stabbed it's
usually your last prayer and you spent
the next
of consciousness when the swelling in
his head
in months after the accident he walked
right down in stairs as if having lost a
corner others grand enough to know
the escape she was be tapping the brain
and once the frontal lobe has been
destroyed you can never know
[Music]
but unfortunately for Phineas our story
won't end there
still no his name is the straightest
part of this affair after his brain
scrambled his friends and family said
[Applause]
Phineas
we know that operating on the brain need
not cause death and that what makes a
person who is it's not the heart of the
head
story Phineas Gage he was stabbed in the
brain and once a frontal lobe has been
destroyed you can never go
Oh Phineas Gage 37 years old when he
finally
his way back to his home and family
everybody could tell the day
finally creaming up
because he forgot to
the tamping
[Music]
severe
trauma seizures - death toll and put an
end to this John
thanks to Catherine and lemon for
helping me film that video lemon
actually didn't help at all I'm sorry we
didn't think to clean the lens
beforehand sorry that I have not
addressed this somewhat pressing concern
of whether or not you can be my Sigma G
player and simply because I'm not
entirely sure I know how to write for
Sigma jig actually I think it's because
I thought you were kidding but now that
I know are you serious I'm gonna do some
research and figure out whether or not I
can write for Singham a Jacob John will
see you on Friday
this is what happens when your camera
Manning and and the dog is tied to you
whatever MacBook I loved Montana